I'm wondering about the crack dosage of Highland 951. So Highland 951 is a
fermented soil that's used to help dislodge estrogens from the beta estrogent
beta receptor cell membrane estrogent and hereto-positive cancers. I've been
taking one teaspoon of the morning, I think I heard it on a zoom one table
school. Thank you. Well, the correct dosage, I'd test for that. So we did a test
for it and you're just taking it, you know, for your own cautionary sake. I would
take it and release the tables for Highland recommends you take a half a
bottle to a full bottle or day. Of course, that's the if person has, you know, got
cancer that's growied and typically breast cancer that's growied. That's what
they would recommend. I think you could get by with a whole lot less than that
but a teaspoon really I don't think is going to do it. You have to take a least
of table spoon. Most of my testing recommendations people have come up anywhere
between five, between three table spoons and, you know, half a bottle a day. So you
need to get out to a dose. With any supplement too, you can be good to
like kind of hyper dose or a period of time usually a week to really saturate
your tissues and then you can back it down to a low dose. That has to do with any
sample that you're checking.